I can yeah hello miss talk-show Queen
boy I don't know about that like looker
like a pauper but I'm trying are you
excited I want to talk about this new
talk show I want to know what is it
about uh-huh we have real life people do
we have celebrities what were you be
talking you know what it's the journey
of life I want people to watch our show
and see themselves I want when you sit
around with your friends like that's
right I know I went through that yes I
did at war oh did you see that did you
hear what that person said I'm gonna go
right and get that book you know I
really want people to know that we have
a shared journey I've over the past
through year two years gone through a
lot of different changes in my life and
just when I feel the loneliest or when I
feel alone five people I went through
the same thing and so for us that's the
show it really is this shared experience
of life talk never goes out of style you
know I don't see our show as some trendy
new thing talk is the very first thing
we do when we have a friend we open up
we share the journey and that's what we
are I think it is it's just a it's a
part of our life yeah well your personal
life beyond the show because you have
know a lot of dangers to share one
single picture of my baby are you
kidding me my child gets more likes on
my social media when in doubt I put up a
Moses picture now of course you know
what I think it is about being real with
people I think that I've always been
real but I've had different roles to
play as a journalist as a part of an
ensemble team and now it is me and a
awesome team of people behind me but I
have to if I want you Keshia to be real
with me I've got to be real with you if
we sit around and you know when I was
single and we're talking about dating
and I'm pretending that it's all perfect
and every day that I ever had worked out
with him proposing to me I would be
lying but if we sit around and we talk
to each other well where did you meet
this person how is that for you then we
build a friendship we build a
relationship so it was and is very
important for me to be vulnerable
because I'm asking you to share that
side of you yeah that's the only way we
can learn that's the only way we can
grow and relationships are built the
best ones are built when you keep it
real when you keep it real keep it 100
you do have a lot of new changes new
husband new baby 48 redefining
motherhood I think that's so
inspirational for so many people I don't
I mean I appreciate that I don't I don't
think I'm read define me let me for me
I'm like wow that's good to know what
listen whoo that's a big one it's
something that I always wanted I didn't
know it would happen at this time in my
life
it's been amazing I I trust me I've seen
the magazines that I'm like oh I didn't
realize 40 it was old then I'm like oh
but it is all and that was also
interesting for me to to to reveal you
know you from 0 to 60 people really
didn't know anything about my personal
life now you know everything including
my IVF journey but yeah I I don't think
I redefined it I don't know that's a lot
but I'm happy to share it and I'm I
moved and I feel I get emotional when
someone like yourself talks about listen
you've given me hope or you know I know
that nothing is perfect and balancing
life and family is an impossible goal
but tamarin kept trying and she found
someone to share this journey wet so I I
know how it feels I was single for a
very very long time and I knew that I
wanted to have someone special in my
life that I could share this with and my
husband happened to be the first person
I ever dated while I wasn't on TV
because I've been on TV a very long time
but it is um it means the world to me
and that's what I know is the payoff is
that when I am reeling when I open up it
does lead to something special like this
conversation we're having and that's
what we're going to do on the show I
think that the minute I walk out there I
just want people to recognize an old
friend that they can be comfortable with
that's that's why I wanted to come back
that there seems to be a theme with
mommy shaming going on
pink Jessica Simpson you but you clap
back me too I really did it
you know honestly my son was with me I
was on a flight and you know where I'm
from you don't say poor baby to anybody
oh I don't know and it just struck me
not for myself because there I was
surrounded by my mother was on the
flight with me my child is there with me
but I did think about all the women who
can't brush it off who can't or don't
have someone to talk to about it and so
I responded and if you look at the women
who wrote after that you know I got
shame I just got back to work after
being away for nine weeks and people
said to me oh you're back already or my
mother-in-law said this and I was
overwhelmed I knew and of course I've
done segments on Mommy's shaming I've
been a morning TV for a long time but to
read how quickly people were willing to
share their personal experiences a it
tells you and me we're not alone on any
journey you're never the only one and be
it told me and really confirm to me that
people want to talk they got on my
Instagram and just started telling me
everything that they were going through
yeah that is the power of communicating
and the power of making people feel safe
to talk thank you so much